Saba was nearly killed at 10 years old
Ace left when he was 17 and Luffy
started his own pirate Adventure three
years later which left these three
adopted Brothers separated until much
later in the story but what if these
three ridiculously strong hits had
somehow stuck together and formed one of
the most exciting pirate Crews ever in
other words what would have happened if
Ace Sabo and Luffy had formed their own
pirate crew and of course everything
would begin back in the Goa Kingdom
where asabo and Luffy all grew up
together in our version of the story
kicks off the moment where the royals
off this island are about to burn this
massive heap of trash town to get rid of
all the poor people to not leave a you
know bad impression on the celestial
dragons who are coming to visit how nice
of them and you might remember that this
is where Ace and Luffy were nearly
killed by these thugs here and after
this event Saba was so disgusted by his
wealthy family that he just wanted to
get the hell out of there and as you
might remember originally he set out in
this little boat right here and got
absolutely crushed by this Celestial
Dragon ship but for our scenario let's
imagine that Luffy and Ace somehow
managed to stop Sabo from leaving the
islands and maybe they kidnap him from
his parents and fake his death or even
intercept him right before he's about to
leave the island and so from here on out
they just continue their lives as they
originally had ever since Luffy joined
to a trio they live up in the mountains
training and growing much stronger until
the day that they are actually ready to
begin their pirate adventure and that
day comes seven years later Ace and Savo
are now both 17 while Luffy is still
only 14. so yeah Luffy's going to set
out way sooner than he did in the
original story and while you might be
saying that he must absolutely wait
until he's 17. I just don't see Ace and
Sabo waiting around until they're 20 to
head out to sea and so in order for
these three to stay together they have
to leave right now this leads them to
buy a ship with all the treasure that
they've stolen so far and they finally
set out into the ocean which you know
seeing how Luffy almost drowned right
away when he first started his own
Journey this could quickly end in
disaster however thankfully Sabo always
had a little bit of an interest in
navigation which helps them to at least
survive let's give him one day at sea
but hold on tight because there are some
major problems coming up very soon but
the first very big and basic question I
guess is where do they go from here
Luffy of course just wants to go
somewhere with some really good food
Saba wants to head to a nearby Island
and Ace wants to track down this
mysterious bounty hunter that he has
heard so much about but with all three
pulling the sails in different
directions all the time they snap the
Mast and their ship is hopelessly broken
right from the start well that uh lasted
only a short time the three drift
helplessly until they crash land on this
Mysterious Island right here however
before we can get into the game-changing
events on this first island let's shift
back to when these three were kids
because back in chapter 585 there is a
super important moment here that we must
understand to see how this crew will
turn out in the future because in this
chapter they basically explain what each
of their individual dreams are Sabo just
wants to be free from the oppression of
his parents on the other hand Ace simply
wants people to know his name and
recognize him for who he is remember
he's still dealing with a lot of Shame
and guilt of being the son of the former
pirate king and Luffy I mean shares his
own secret dream nope not becoming the
king of pirates but the one we are still
to this day actually waiting to learn in
the current Story Probably to throw a
giant party or something like that
however Ace and Zabo do think it's
hilarious but then we get to their first
real point of conflict and one of the
reasons that they never made a crew in
the first place in the original version
and that's because of course they all
basically assume that they would of
course be the captain of their own ship
and the others would join their crew but
none of the three obviously wanted that
so they had originally decided to meet
up again once there were all strong
Pirates and so fast forward again to
their current situation and the three
are now Shipwrecked on this island which
by the way is from the ace novel big
recommendation if you haven't read that
and they meet this crusty fellow called
Mast juice now juice was also
Shipwrecked on this island and they're
basically stuck and starving until Ace
just like in the original story finds
this random mysterious looking fruit a
very hungry dudes nearly kills Ace to
get that fruit but after Ace takes this
first bite he shares the rest with
everyone else and just like originally
this of course gives Ace his fire powers
and now with his new abilities and
Luffy's devil fruit Powers they're able
to make a very decent raft to help them
get off the islands and Deuce of course
comes along as the First new member of
that crew and he's not just some random
guy he acts actually comes from a
medical family so he will serve as the
cruise doctor oh but but wait aren't we
forgetting something I mean a new crew
also needs a name so at this point they
decide to call themselves The sakea
Pirates based on the sake cups that
represent their bond as brothers and so
now their four member crew is going to
need a new ship as well so whatever
island they find next they manage to
steal a boat and continue on their
Journey however instead of heading
straight for the grand line they
actually decide to be smart for once and
spend some more time gaining experience
in these blue and looking for other
members of course they still don't have
an official Captain yet but they
surprisingly decide on some sort of
democratic system of voting on where to
go next which basically just leads to
them traveling around for a while
defeating other pirate Crews and making
a name for themselves and while Luffy
himself is younger and weaker than he
was when he first set out in the normal
story this is more than made up for by
having the powerful Ace in by his side
plus they have spent all those years
continuing to train together all three
of them so I think this version of Luffy
might actually be even stronger than
normal Luffy at age 14. and so during
these roughly six months they spent in
these blue they actually meet and
recruit usop now usop is also younger
but he is still an orphan the whole
conflict on his Island isn't even
happening yet so there's really no one
to defeat here still usop and Luffy get
along really well so that Luffy invites
him to join and usop accepts however
they don't get the going Mary of course
since they never actually saved USA
Village in fact it's not looking that
great for his village later on in the
story but there's actually a very
similar circumstance with Sanji because
after the sake cup Pirates come to this
floating restaurant to recruit a cook
let's just say they somehow convince
Sanji to join them as well maybe death
once again kicks him out or he decides
to follow his Dreams by himself to find
the all-blue on the other hand Nami
joining is a little bit more of an issue
here because remember that Nami
originally only joined Luffy to steal
his money and then after he rescued her
and the village she actually wanted to
become part of the crew however in this
version of the story The sakika Pirates
definitely wouldn't encounter this clown
pirate yet because he would not have
invaded orange town until years later in
other words no initial encounter with
nami however I definitely think that the
sakika Pirates would eventually come to
nami's islands and while Ace would
probably not want to get involved with
the Fishman Sabo and Luffy would never
stand for the people of the island being
enslaved by arlong and so in their first
major fight the three of them together
beat down the notorious Fishman and save
the people of the village this leads
Nami to officially join the crew and
while Sabo is also a navigator Nami is
literally going to be the greatest
Navigator in the story so he can't take
a backseat to our orange-haired
navigating goddess okay so let's check
Usopp Sanji Nami and wait aren't we
missing someone now remember that we're
still about two and a half years before
the start of the original story so Zorro
would definitely not have been captured
at Shell town and would still be out and
about bounty hunting which in other
words means it is very likely that the
green haired Swordsmen would cross paths
with the sake cup Pirates and I think
that they would actually develop some
sort of respectful rivalry over the next
months where basically Zorro keeps
coming after them but is beaten down
each time by one of the brothers and
then at the last moment before the sake
cup Pirates head to the Grand line he
then tries to beat them one last time of
course he would fail after all it's all
three of them but the crew would then
invite him to join them on their
adventure and he would agree I mean what
better way to become the world's
strongest swordsman right so bam the
gang is all here with a few extras and
let's continue forward to all of the
unbelievable changes that are gonna come
up in the grand line and the
mind-blowing future that awaits this
incred incredibly young crew now again
Luffy and the other original straw hats
are still about two and a half years
younger than they were before but that
also means that events cannot play out
just like they did in the original story
in other words this won't just be the
speedrun version of the grand line that
Luffy and core are doing in the original
story as the crew will take more time
and take it more slowly going from
Island to Island and exploring a little
bit and of course things are going to be
much different for example Alabaster
would not be having its Civil War quite
yet so we will basically just skip that
entire Arc which means no Robin for now
and since Mass Deuce is the cruise
doctor the crew don't go looking for
another one so we do not get chopper as
well and before we go any further
there's actually still one super
important thing that we haven't yet
discussed in terms of the power dynamics
of that crew you see after six months in
the East blue Zabo Ace and Luffy have
all gotten much much stronger and
especially Ace with his low gear powers
can easily take on nearly anyone that
they meet in this part of the world and
at least for now Luffy would very likely
still be the weakest of the Three
Brothers but that Gap is starting to
close pretty rapidly now and at this
point the crew would probably still want
to go up to skypeia so that whole Arc
continues pretty much normally and if
I'm not mistaken the lightning fruit
user NL should already be oppressing the
sky pians at that point too and while
the others aren't too sure about getting
involved Luffy absolutely refuses to
leave without freeing the people from
this false gods the rest of the crew
actually begrudgingly supports this
decision and so they start the battle
Luffy and Ace can certainly fight with
NL with their robber and logia powers
and I think Saba would be smart enough
to find some sort of sea stone or dial
to be able to contribute to the fight as
well and eventually they managed to take
down the lightning man which would also
basically ruin his plans to go to the
moon since his art Maxime was not yet
completed although they would not be
able to decipher the poniglyph next to
the Golden Bell because Robin is not
with them at this time and now with this
country freed and after they of course
have a massive party the crew can now
continue back down to the ocean with one
major change in the crew structure
because I do feel like by this point the
crew might be ready to accept Luffy as
the actual Captain after all he is the
most headstrong and determined to help
others he has recruited most people plus
both Ace and Sabo eventually joined
other Crews thus being the emperor
Whitebeard for Ace and the Revolutionary
Army for Sabo so I don't really think
that it's that much of a stretch to
think that they would both eventually be
okay with Luffy being the captain
especially of course because Luffy's
dream to become pirate king is gonna be
the goal that unites everyone else's
dream as well Ace has already made a
pretty good name for himself and has
people who love him Sabo is free and
helps free oppressed countries so really
Luffy is the only one driving everyone
forward here and this doesn't mean that
Luffy will make every single decision
from here on out because he doesn't even
do do that with the current crew but he
still becomes the captain and this is a
super important decision that will be
tested right away because after the
rigorous journey to reach the sky
islands the sake cup cruise ship is in
very bad shape now remember that this is
not the going Mary since they did not
get her from usop's Hometown but still I
think the crew would no doubt have some
sort of attachment to that current ship
and so this could be a case where the
crew actually might be split again on
buying a new ship or repairing the
current one but just like in the
original story I think Luffy would
probably see the need to buy a new ship
anyways and on top of that we wouldn't
get the whole usop leaving drama since
he isn't as attached to this particular
ship so with a new one and probably a
new ship ride crewmate the crew depart
from Saba OD wait what what what what
about Frankie what about Anna's Lobby
well at this point the crew doesn't even
have Robin so there would be no way for
these government secret agents to
Blackmail them and the whole Saga was
the reason that the crew befriended
Frankie in the first place so if none of
that happens then they wouldn't be able
to have Frankie built a thousand sunny
or recruit him into the crew but they
would still need a ship ride so maybe
they recruited this guy Paulie who is
constantly running from gambling that
anyways so wow this is uh shaping up to
be a pretty incredible crew but if you
want to know the saddest thing about
this group no Frankie means that we will
never have the straw Hat's strongest
combo attack the pirate ducking six but
you can still use your most overpowered
combo attack to smash that subscribe
button below this video and even without
Frankie there's much more insane things
to come for this headstrong crew now
from here on out they continue to sail
around before eventually getting sucked
into the zombie infested Thriller bark
where they still meet and recruit Brooke
because Luffy has always wanted a
musician certainly no major changes here
and after curb stomping the shadow man
the group then very comfortably sails
onto Saba ODI and it is right here where
we're going to dive into the truly
game-changing alterations to the story
because at sabaori everything is going
to go smoothly
that's right the craziest part is that
nothing crazy happens here I mean they
would probably still somehow meet this
mermaid who would then introduce them to
the former right hand of the pirate king
Silva's Rayleigh and Rayleigh of course
would be super excited to meet them all
after learning about them from Shanks
and he immediately agrees to coat their
ship so they can travel under the grand
line towards Fishman islands and with
his two older brothers watching over him
Luffy stays out of trouble in fact
Rayleigh even gives the crew a hardcore
crash course training camp which we'll
be talking about in just a moment and
then after just a few days they dive
underwater towards Fishman Islands so if
you're following along that means no
two-year time skip which is of course a
huge change to the story that is going
to have massive consequences for the
next part of this version of course this
means that we're skipping all of the
summit War Saga so no Amazon Lily no
imple down or even Marine for it because
this time the donut man is still safe
and sound and with Luffy inside which of
course makes this the perfect time to
talk about the world government because
at this time the sake cup Pirates are
starting to get pretty famous Luffy a
Sabo and even zaro would probably all be
part of the worst generation of upcoming
Pirates but the world government would
not care about them nearly as much as
they hated the straw hats in the
original story that's because there was
no Fiasco in Alabaster no shooting down
the flag at Anna's Lobby No Stealing
Robin from the zp9 or punching a
Celestial Dragon so to the world
government this is just another group of
pretty annoying Pirates although they
would probably still be keeping a close
eye on Luffy and Ace because of their
lineage and since there is no Marine
Forge that means Luffy didn't spend all
that time training during the time skip
however as I just mentioned they did get
a crash course training with Rayleigh
right before they left for Fishman
islands where the dark King himself at
least showed them the basic idea of
hockey and so of course characters like
Sabo Sanji or zaro who don't have devil
fruits will be especially excited to
finally learn hockey so that they can
actually continue to be able to fight
strong devil fruit users now at this
point the sakika Pirates are a pretty
fearsome group they sailed through
Fishman Island and the early parts of
the new world without too much trouble
I'd say but everything changes when they
encounter the Whitebeard pirates on some
random Islands which is of course a
mind-blowing event for this crew because
up until now they've never faced off
against any of the top tier fighters of
the world of course the sakika Pirates
get beaten down pretty badly by the
emperor's crew and now I could imagine
that just like in the original story
Whitebeard might invite all of them to
join his crew and while Ace originally
did actually accept this offer I don't
think that Luffy would ever agree to
work under anyone else so wipe it could
either kill them here or the much more
likely case I think is that he would let
them go because he sees something
special in Luffy and the crew which is a
very lucky break because not everyone
survives an encounter with an empress
crew and so some more time passes as
they sail around the new world getting
stronger they're not exploring new
islands fighting strong opponents and
growing much in their own powers and
Luffy would probably have mastered at
least gear second and third at the stage
maybe even four if he practiced his
hockey enough and so now at this point
one year has passed in the new world and
where roughly one year behind the
original storyline and eventually we
come to one of the most dangerous places
in the new world wano where the sake cup
Pirates are in for their next rude
awakening because as they travel up the
waterfall the crew gets separated just
like in the original story now remember
we're still too early in the timeline
for this to play out like normal wano
the samurai for example who were sent
forward in time have not yet arrived but
the country is still being dominated by
kaido and Luffy being Luffy he would of
course want to save the oppressed people
there and so just like in the original
Luffy on his own eventually leads to a
major Smackdown by kaido and Luffy is
thrown in jail once again at this same
time Sabo Ace and the rest of the crew
have come to onigashima looking for
Luffy where they encounter kaido's child
Yamato and quickly become friends Yamato
despite her handcuffs would of course
want to join the crew and together they
had to save Luffy from udon prison and
so we can argue a little bit about the
Battle here and if the crew would
actually be able to defeat this funky
dinosaur but eventually the crew manages
to save Luffy as well as this Samurai
Fishman kawamatsu plus this Grandpa here
who teaches the three about Rio which
ultimately leads to A's freeing Yamato
from her shackles now Luffy's of course
fired up to make another attempt at the
boss but kawamatsu who was one of the
legendary retainers of Odin tells them
that the time to free wano has not yet
arrived and so instead he asked him to
come back in three years to help
liberate wano from kaido's tyrannical
role and despite Luffy really wanting to
help right now especially with Tom and
so on and so forth the crew departs and
now things become really interesting
because with Yamato on board we have a
top tier fighter on the crew who can now
finally teach everyone about conquerors
and advanced forms of haki which brings
us to another super important stretch of
the story now because we skipped over
much of the normal New World Islands but
I do think one art that was incredibly
important is the home of the Minx which
is Zoe now kawamatsu should know about
Zoe since the kozuki and the Mings are
actually Ally so before separating
kawamatsu gives them a Viva card that
will help them find the massive
elephants onisha as a result this leads
the sakika Pirates to finally climb up
the elephant where they then make
friends with the animal Minx however the
major question here is do the Ming's
show Luffy and the crude opponent glyphs
I mean you could argue that they would
probably not since there is no one from
the Kazuki Clan with the crew right now
plus they wouldn't have just saved the
entire truck I mean who knows maybe they
have a letter from kawamatsu who tells
them leaders to show them the pony
glyphs but even if they do get to see
that road Pony live there and learn all
about the secret Stones they definitely
can't read it yet and honestly I think
it's just more reasonable that they
don't get to see the pony glyphs here
still it would be one step closer to
Luffy's dream of becoming the pirate
king they could even take on a new
crewmate like Pedro who wanted to serve
the next pirate king or carrot might
sneak aboard even if she wasn't invited
now after so they continue sailing
through the new world and practicing the
advanced forms of hockey at this point I
would say that Luffy Sabo and Ace and
probably even Zorro are definitely above
warlord power level so they can pretty
easily defeat people as the Sanford use
a crocodile and the stringfoot user to
Flamingo which will be important in just
a few moments however they are still
under matched against any of the yonko
and when they next encounter Whitebeard
they are once again defeated by the
World's Strongest Man and his crew
however at this point Whitebeard is
getting older and sick and the battle is
much closer than it was the first time
and so with Whitebeard very impressed by
how much the socket cup crew has grown
in such a short time I think they would
probably become allies and could even
exchange Viva cards and around this time
they could also of course find elbath
where Shanks could be waiting but I
still don't think Shanks would be quite
ready to acknowledge Luffy yet and so
they might just end up skipping this
island for now but one Island that they
would definitely have to go to is a road
star now in case you forgot Road Star or
lodestar is the last Island officially
of the grand line and it's originally
where Pirates are supposed to learn
about the ponoglyphs and even though the
sake cup Pirates might have already
learned about them from Zoe this would
be a great place to stop because it
would help them learn more about the
mysterious stones and although Luffy
does have the voice of all things it is
not quite the same as someone who can
literally read them and this might
actually set them on a path to cross the
red line and sail the entire Grand line
once again to find the opponent glyphs
and someone who can rate them just like
Roger did back in his days although I do
feel like Ace might not be that happy
that they're literally following in his
Father's Footsteps regardless this now
very overpowered crew goes all the way
back to reverse mountain and starts the
journey once again and this time they
Liberate the islands that they skipped
in the past for example crocodile would
already have taken control of alabaster
and the Civil War might already be over
but Luffy Ace and Sabo could come in and
take down the warlord and this would
also be the perfect time for Robin to
join the crew as well which means that
zp9 could also try to blackmail her once
again but this might be a good thing
actually because the crew would have no
trouble smacking down these secret
agents here and we it just feels good to
see the crew dealing some punishment
after they took such a beating in the
original story and so now with Robin
back on board and fully trusting the
crew they can return to the new world
saving islands and finding more Pony
glyphs and this would probably be how
their Journey continues for a little bit
more the crew might even establish a
home-based island and somewhere in the
new world but then something would
happen that shakes the entire pirate
world that's because Blackbeard betrays
Whitebeard and steals the darkness logia
fruits and once again just like in the
original this single event is going to
set off a crazy chain reaction that
massively affects the entire story
Blackbeard could still become a warlord
he could still break into imple down and
gather a stupidly powerful crew and go
around collecting devil fruits and then
he could eventually return to challenge
Whitebeard in a straight up War which is
actually not Blackbeard's style but with
Whitebeard sick and already dying I
think that he would certainly try to
kill Whitebeard and then actually take
his legendary devil fruit however
remember that at this point the sake cup
crew and whitebeard's crew were
basically allies and when the crew
notices whitebeard's Weaver cards
disintegrating they would do everything
in their power to save him however they
would most likely be too late at this
point but this would definitely
definitely still set up the faded
showdown between Blackbeard and Luffy
and of course once again there are tons
of ways that this battle could possibly
go I mean Blackbeard is so sneaky that
he could still trick Luffy somehow and
defeat the entire crew but the sake cup
Pirates are so insanely powerful at this
point that it might not really matter
sabon Ace would be nearly as strong if
not as strong as Luffy plus with Yamato
zaro and Sanji I feel like there's just
no way that they could all lose to the
darkness Logan fruit user who barely
just got his second devil fruit and
barely got his crew together however I
do think it would be very fitting that
during this battle Luffy finally awakens
his mythical sun god Nika fruit because
this would undoubtedly help him to feed
blackbeards and together with his
brothers they would avenge whitebeard's
death which means of course that after
this battle the sake cup crew would be
on a whole different level I mean some
of the white bit Pirates might join
Luffy would surely become a new emperor
and the only thing stopping them from
finding the one piece would be the last
few Road Pony glyphs and the other yonko
however stop one opponent that we
haven't really mentioned that much in
this storyline is the world government
in fact they might see Luffy as so much
of a threat after Awakening his devil
fruit that they slap him with a bouncy
way higher than anything the world has
ever seen at this point their goal would
be to make Luffy the number one target
of every Marine bouncy Hunter and pirate
in the entire world which is just an
absurdly insane Target to have painted
on your back in fact turning it all up
to 11 I actually might have figured out
exactly how having an insane 100 billion
Berry bouncy would change Luffy's
journey and you can watch that video
right here thanks for watching and I
will see you in the next one